und es stimmt meinen namen katja
[Musik]
richtiger zufall dass hier die kamera
schon etwas gedacht und jetzt willkommen
beim neuen video leute heute steht ein
ganz ganz besonderes video an wir haben
gerade 11 uhr 58 also noch zwei minuten
ich hoffe dann kommt das auch wirklich
online mir wurde gesagt es kommt um 12
anleihen und zwar veröffentlicht die
youtube in katja krawiec dann kann ich
immer noch nicht aussprechen den ersten
eigenen song namens lobby haben ja
vorgestern schon ein video dazu gemacht
und haben unseren eigenen katja song
gemacht vielleicht hier meinen kurzen
ausschnitt
[Musik]
es ist schwer aber ich bin jetzt
wirklich mehr gespannt auf das original
ich glaube wenn wir uns an baby zurück
erinnern
wir haben jetzt zwölf world wide web hat
jetzt zwei millionen alter dafür ein
deutsches video ist das schon ultra
krankengeld mal sehen wieviel cut
geschafft
wir haben 12 uhr und ich weiß nicht ob
es online es ist online vor 37 sekunden
oh mein gott ich bin gespannt alltag ich
bin richtig gespannt vor allem die
meisten sollten jetzt noch in der schule
sein
und ich wette wenn ich jetzt drauf gehe
hat das schon ich sage es hat jetzt 600
des lacks umgeht von gar nicht 80
display 485 like okay leute das
highlight meines heutigen tages startet
jetzt die schauspielerische leistung
gibt's auf jeden fall schon krass da man
gucken wir der pizzabote
[Musik]
also ich muss sagen kann hier glaube ich
immer noch so ein paar auszuteilen wenn
nur die story dahinter das so hat er
jetzt einen pizzaboten verführt oder so
finde ich eigentlich schon echt cool
also ich meine so etwas habe ich sonst
noch nirgendwo gesehen und man muss
sagen also das ganze ist ja bis jetzt
mehr so repp als singen und für mich es
hat sich jetzt gar nicht so schlecht an
gehört also ich habe es wirklich der
erste eindruck ich hätte ihnen viel
schlechter eingeschätzt natürlich war
klar das ist um mit geht aber wir
schauen wir weiter
ok jetzt legen sie und spaß
ich hatte jetzt wirklich gedacht das ist
wieder so eine sache wird wo man
eigentlich nur was schlechtes zu sagen
kann aber ich finde es wirklich gar
nicht schlecht so also natürlich wäre
das jetzt kein song für mich den ich mir
zwingen jeden tag anhören muss aber der
euro um faktor ist auf jeden fall
darunter gesang jetzt im refrain ist
natürlich nichts weltbewegendes aber er
ist auch nicht schlecht also ich muss
wirklich sagen man sollte jetzt nicht
zwangshaft hätten
schlecht ist es nicht wieso habt ihr
eigentlich nicht mich gefragt ob ich
damit machen will
[Musik]
also ich werde auf jeden fall zeit
gehabt
[Musik]
ich hatte euch diesen blick einfach den
titel wird oft an zeit mit spielen ich
nicht ist ja eine frechheit was wir da
wie man es macht mir okay leute das ding
ist jetzt zehn minuten online und wir
haben
3100 likes und 1306 gar nicht mal so
schlecht ich komme meint hier echt sehr
sehr selten youtube-videos aber hier
muss jetzt einfach mal schreiben ich
finds überraschend gut auf jeden fall
natürlich sollte man dazu sagen das kann
er vermutlich jetzt nicht so viel daran
geleistet haushalt dass ein zu rappen
oder einzusingen das video gefällt mir
war echt ganz gut also das ist cool
gemacht über den songtext lässt sich
jetzt natürlich streiten also eigentlich
repräsentiert er nur das was die ganzen
videos von ihr auch schon tun also da
hab ich eigentlich auch nichts anderes
erwartet er bietet aber echt ganz geil
und ja an sich kann ich das jetzt will
ich das gar nicht helfen so ich find's
ok ich finde es cool kann man erst mal
anhören viele von euch werden
wahrscheinlich eine andere meinung haben
aber das ist meine ehrliche meinung so
schlecht finde ich gar nicht
ja leute also das war meine erste
reaktion darauf ich habe glaube ich
sonst noch nie auf irgendwas reagiert
also zumindest von anderen youtuber
nicht wir sehen uns schon morgen wieder
morgen kommt ein iphone extrem stark
schlug also schnick schnack schnuck um
den iphone extras und ja haut rein